y temor por una posible crisis nuclear
en la mayor central de europa que se
encuentra cerca de la línea del frente
de batalla en el sureste de ucrania los
daños causados por los ataques del
viernes a la central nuclear es a
purilla provocaron la parada automática
de uno de los reactores de la planta
según la empresa estatal ucraniana de
energía nuclear que sigue gestionando en
la central ahora ocupada por las tropas
rusas la estación de nitrógeno oxígeno y
un edificio auxiliar resultaron
seriamente dañados como resultado del
bombardeo sigue habiendo riesgo de fuga
de hidrógeno y sustancias radiactivas y
el riesgo de incendio también es alto
rafael grossi director del organismo
internacional de energía atómica dijo
que el bombardeo subraya el riesgo muy
real de un desastre nuclear añadiendo
que cualquier fuego militar dirigido
hacia o desde la instalación equivaldría
a jugar con fuego con consecuencias
potencialmente catastróficas
rusia y ucrania intercambiaron culpas
tras el bombardeo de la planta que fue
tomada por las fuerzas rusas en marzo
alrededor de una semana después del
inicio de la invasión de ucrania
mientras que este domingo el presidente
de ucrania
excellence que pidió sanciones más
drásticas para rusia en lo que calificó
como terrorismo nuclear
hablé con sound michelle él le conté
sobre la situación en el campo de
batalla en particular en la central
nuclear de sabor y allá el terrorismo
nuclear ruso requiere una respuesta más
fuerte de la comunidad internacional
sanciones a la industria nuclear rusa
mientras tanto el ministerio de defensa
de reino unido dijo que las fuerzas
rusas estaban probablemente operando en
el área adyacente a la planta
utilizándola para lanzar ataques y para
que sus tropas descansarán sabiendo muy
bien que las tropas de ucraniano se
arriesgarían a atacar el sitio al
principio de la guerra el jefe de la
empresa estatal de energía nuclear de
ucrania había pedido que se estableciera
una zona de seguridad de 30 kilómetros
alrededor de las centrales del país